welcome to this video continued coverage
of my tournament that I played in my
yarmulke on my orca this nice island in
the mediterranean sea yo en pinning
fifth rounds now so i was on three out
of four points winning the first three
games and losing in round four against a
strong GM and the fifth round was a
close call it was it was them in terms
of the pairings it was very close that
actually would be still the bottom half
of them of this group of players but
they turned out that I was still part of
the the the top group so I got a
somewhat weaker opponent um relatively
speaking is he was a feed master called
Adela shy she i'm probably
mispronouncing this and I'm sorry for
that but it's difficult he was rated
2213 so um he had lost quite a bit of
points from the days when he was a when
he got the feed master title you need
2302 to get this I mean not not an old
player so he was in his 30s or early 30s
yeah I plead black in this game and when
I looked at his games for the for the
preparation I noticed that he was son
very predictable he all the time played
c4e 493 and g3 this very typical setup
at least he plated in all cases where it
was possible I mean so what I was trying
to do is to get a position type that
normally also he played c4 in the game
master was a predicted I wanted to get a
position type that it's that is somewhat
unconventional and sort of gets it gets
him out of his comfort zone so I pretty
much immediately ruled out to play
something like c-54
after which she will will do just
something like that going from somewhat
dry and symmetrical position so what did
I do I played the English Defence like I
also often do when recording the videos
it has a very distinct advantage over
some other defenses against c4 it is
immediately aiming against the g3 me
with wide no place g3 what he normally
does he plays c43 I get Bishop d7 in and
yeah this kind of position already is
very half from the normal patterns that
players going for the English strive for
yeah he played efore now and then 93
this makes some sense he goes for this
efore c4 anyway but yeah as we have
maybe already seen in one of my blitz
games this has some twists e6 and now he
played g3 yeah according to his usual
taste here when white goes for this type
of setup was g3 has two or even three
move orders you can start with g3 lucky
in the game I can play 92 sometimes 92
years recommended preparing g3 the idea
is that after 92 of course the move f5
does not make any sense as white can
just take it and leave black was weird
poor information after g3 f5 as possible
and was played in the game maybe 92 is
the more um testing move order here
after that black girl needs to do to
switch plans you cannot play with f5
anymore but you have other possibilities
black can go for an entirely different
set I would see five if he wants I can
play Knight f6 and this would have been
my choice probably because it takes him
completely out of his usual patterns in
needs to do something with the e4 pawn
like 93 maybe or even advanced it and
this is totally unlike um yeah he played
g3 and so f5 if I was glad to have this
position Bishop g2 Knight f6 putting
pressure on e4 with all pieces so weiter
needs to to cover that and now I took
only four here's an important point here
he probably didn't expect the opening I
guess there is no b6 type of game in
life in my games in the main databases
that are available um and I don't think
he watches my channel so he couldn't
expect the whole thing um still he
played the the the best move order he
played 92 this is better than taking on
e4 immediately and for a specific reason
if white takes on the phone now with the
pawn or you can also insert these moves
in both cases black gets a very easy
game with Bishop c5 aiming directly at
f2 with castling even the FR gets into
play that's a very nice position already
44 black the important thing is also
that white has weakened the d4 square
considerably here in the structure black
sometimes just gets in knight c6 v5 and
then put a piece on deform this is what
white wants to avoid until a pre started
with 92 and this is a very clever move
now I need to commit somehow and yeah
what what can I do I cannot take only
for obviously it's a pin I played 96 and
this was part of my preparation just
playing the night out Bishop before is
also not a terribly bad move but very
often I prefer to preferred on c5 so 96
is good now d3 is really hanging so he
needs to take if he takes with the pawn
we have the same story again with this
bishop coming on
on c5 and this is a very serious matter
if why does not really paying any
attention it can be very problematic
quickly look at this just for example if
white now plays a somewhat routine move
let's say be three yeah I'm playing Naja
for and already winning the game if toys
is simply collapsing it's very very
problematic yeah so he played the right
movie took on d4 with the night and this
has been seen before and still was what
I looked at before 94 and now he took
with the bishop for the same reasoning d
takes Bishop c5 is again a good play
with d 4 + f2 big targets Bishop takes
and now I played Queen f6 yeah I very
much like this this idea quickly going
for long castling and we could put this
on the board and this is the exact
position that I wanted to have to have a
somewhat unconventional position that is
somewhat outside his his normal a normal
area of position types that he has very
often at this very schematic English
positions and this is just totally
unconventional yeah okay play deform
this is a good move yeah I was intending
to play Bishop c5 and maybe occupying
this square on d4 so why it goes d for
himself this makes make sense yeah and
what I remembered in my preparation lost
d5 which are played capturing and then
there was this move night before this I
had had looked briefly before and black
seemed to be okay there was a game of
well known play and mostly author John
Watson the well-known theoretician who
is most famous for his work on the
French defence he made a video series on
icc on the English Defence and he
recommended this this line which he also
had played
that you also have played himself in a
game against very strong Mexican
grandmaster lee on horse what's enum got
a comfortable position in this in this
game after this night before Bishop f4
Bishop g5 this was played maybe Bishop
d6 is even more precise I vaguely
remembered that at the board that I had
looked at this I mean had looked at many
lines so it's not like you just remember
one one single thing that you looked at
but at them when I was at the board I
was thinking okay what about it takes d5
is this a bad move not before it's not
bad but it also simplifies matters a bit
and I was thinking okay why not e takes
d5 and i played this e takes d5 Bishop
g2 what else and then g5 this is what I
had seen and I kind of liked this idea
g5 is some occupying or controlling
occupying is wrong controlling f form so
that he cannot easily put a night on f4
or Bishop on f4 it allows Bishop g7
intensifying the pressure against the
deform and yeah well he takes d5 when it
closes the diagonal but it also controls
important square c endure in the center
it keeps pieces on the board I didn't
see anything great um against it so I
went for it it it's a very interesting
position he played Bishop e3 this is
what i expected looks very normal need
to get the bishop out maybe prepare Luke
see one maybe get something against g5
are very normal yeah here I wasn't
really sure what what piece had up is
best what it was pretty clear that the
knight on c6 is not well placed and it
should probably go to f5 at some point
but I wasn't sure if I should initiate
that right away because yeah it also
puts some pressure on d foyer like with
Bishop g7 on
or similar so at the end term not after
a long time I decided to play King b8
first I think this is really a good move
as it is quite often very useful to have
the King on beard instead of see it it
goes out of possible checks here a move
with the Queen and the bishop when it
wasn't c8 there was always this
possibility in the air and of course a
seven is protected in case the night
moves there is no Queen a4 with the
tempo so I think this is a good move and
it while I was playing it I was thinking
about a little joke that sometimes it's
made by a German Grand Master Klaus
Bischoff very well-known German veteran
Grandmaster is also famous a commentator
in German chess and he is always saying
that long castles is called long castles
because it actually takes two moves you
always have to play king be one knocking
v8 later this is why this long castles
takes longer yeah in a way this is to
very often you you need to play this
moves or they are very useful ok I'll
keep plate Knight c3 also what I
expected at least one of the moves that
I thought of it it takes d5 yeah I not
plate 97 this was according to plan
anyway because night f5 I thought was on
the agenda however what I didn't see
here is that he's not really threatening
d5 I didn't think about this too long in
fact I played the whole game really
quickly because I noticed after a couple
of moves and he was taking lot rather
lots of time in positions where I
thought ok here you can play relatively
quick move and then I started to get
quicker myself to put more pressure on
him on the clock the whole game mountain
I only spent I don't know bit more than
30 minutes to to get the pressure on and
this is sometimes a good recipe if you
feel you have a good move just just play
it out and
increase the pressure on your opponent
when especially in this kind of somewhat
quicker time controls however here
instead of playing the quick 97 which of
course makes sense i also had Bishop g7
which are only looked at later with the
computer the thing is white cannot take
on d5 this is not really hanging after
Queen f7 and threatening rook takes d5
getting two pieces for the rook and what
needs to retreat now and after 94 black
has a totally dominating position in the
center the knight on d4 is just very
strong and yeah something like that is
probably what white needs to do you
cannot keep the night there something
like that is just an excellent position
so white cannot take on on d5 after
Bishop g7 and when it detects t4 so it
is it is interesting um there are black
is not the winning or anything white can
play moves like Queen age 5 or grenade
for ya it would have been interesting to
consider but this is not bad um yet here
he totally surprised me I was I was I
was really really a completely surprised
because I didn't think of this move at
all he played Queen h5 in this position
um I was only expecting white to do
something on the queenside as well this
is where my king is on be aight i mostly
expected moves like rook see one or a 4
a-4 was my my my first candidate moved
here like a four a five um and I thought
this was was reasonably good for white a
form it was interesting to look at I
mean a five as a response is very
weakening on the queenside and the white
has clearly gained here even if you just
compare this to the game continuation
this would have been highly favorable in
comparison so queen age five he is much
stronger as it is stronger than in the
game
I probably wouldn't have played a five
year but go for night f5s planned and
then white can go a five something like
this for example is a very unclear
situation white can cover III with the
Queen here and can do something on the
FR it's just a sharp position but this
is what I wanted I wanted a nessa
metrical position to play for when of
course I didn't really mention that
before I mean this is a must-win
situation in this kind of tournament if
you were a paired against guide 200
points lower and you want to to play on
the top boards and get good opponents
you need to win basically against all
over rated opponents you can afford a
draw maybe at some point losing is
especially especially bed of course but
you really want the win and absolutely
wanted to win the game I mean taking
risk and everything to win was was clear
beforehand so i would have welcomed this
position but he didn't do that in oly
plate queen age five it is not bad I'm
just saying I was totally surprised I
was only thinking about about Queen side
plane okay here plate and rook g8
relatively quickly um g5 was really
hanging I cannot ignore it h6 looks
weird it does nothing for them for
blacks development or peace coordination
and in addition there is the direct move
f4 after which are not quite sure what
black should play what however was
interesting was bishop age 6 this is
somewhat surprisingly for me favorite
bye bye the engines um it looks a bit
unnatural but it works against this f4
idea as black can just simply take them
does not seem to be bad really I went
rogue g8 also I think a good move um
yeah and now well one thing that needs
to mention is what about the h7 pawn
it's not a very human move to take the
poem but it seems that white could have
done it it's not
it does not seem to be a mistake I only
looked at this very briefly in the game
it was a bit of a bit of a poker
decision I mean I was thinking okay if
he takes it okay so be it I have the H
file and this looks like so computer
rich this move and yeah he does he
didn't didn't do that I mean
specifically I think I thought group g 6
would be interesting cutting off the
Queen and then go nite f5 however after
something like f form you know this is
not clear at all f 4g for f5 night takes
and now let's say root game AE 1 this is
a totally totally messy position white
could have taken on 87 but it's not a
very human decision and it didn't do
that his plan was a form after all and
this is what he played I think that's
also the the most consistent yeah of
course I went 0 ng form I don't want to
open it up something like taking is
really not what I want something like
this right now enjoys the F file and
this does not make much sense I wanted
to do this due to this and after g4 of
course Black now has a very serious
strategical threat now night at five
probably that's not only a strategical
threat as the Queen Esther is in some in
some trouble after that but night f5 is
also a positional threat blocking the
whole position and killing both bishops
and white white Bishop on d510 sometimes
and just be blunted with c6 and
especially of course the e3 Bishop is a
very sorry piece after night f5 which
also puts pressure on d4 and looks at
the e3 Square and that I've thought
makes White's next move almost forced
but he didn't play the move that I
considered to be forced um and in a way
I think this is the result of this
position being so on and Orthodox um
that he simply couldn't couldn't manage
the the 10
what white absolutely should do is to
play a five I only considered this move
to be honest I thought everything else
must be a excellent for black and yeah
after f5 the situation is very unclear
um I add in the during the game I had
some doubts even if this is ok for black
but ok I had decided I wanted to to play
for win and addressing something so ok
so be it it's in fact not so bad on my
idea was of course after f5 to attack
this pawn with Bishop f5 and I mean why
does white player 5 it's really to
prevent night f5 yeah from the black
side end to make sure that this Bishop
is doing something it's just the most
active means yeah Bishop c8 is what I
have intended to do increasing the
pressure on the f5 pawn this point is of
course yeah strength and weakness at the
same time the probable continuation here
is after Bishop c8 something like let's
say rook a to e one more than one more
possible but this is what I thought
during the game night f5 95 and Queen g6
yeah and this is a really complicated
unclear position that certainly is not
bad for white you can only argue um yeah
I think this is within a range of equal
or slight edge for one side but but very
hard to to determine if you look at
something like this for example this
should be ok for black black does not
have any bad piece has got some play
against you for but white is also active
the rooks are active the pieces are all
good I mean the computer gives it as
totally equal and
that may be true for computer but this
still would have been a position well
we're a verified would occur it's not
like a doll draw position or something
but this is what white absolutely needed
to do with their five he didn't do that
he played Queen to e5 again a move that
really am surprised me because well I
had considered it briefly but I thought
okay what exactly is the point if I go
Bishop g7 which I did and rather quickly
I'm now threatening Queen f7 basically
trapping the Queen so what is his move
after Bishop g7 I thought okay f5 is not
possible anymore or I mean it does not
really help him I can even consider to
to grab here one possibility not clear
f6 is a move or I can play d4 him which
is also interesting looks very good at
first because of the pin and sorry
because of the fork but there's also
this fork um okay f5 I thought maybe
possible but even then I can I don't
don't need to take I can play a move
like this again threatening Queen f7 or
threatening to move the Queen somewhere
else he took and while this cannot
really be a yeah stern test off of
blacks position this Queen h5 f6 and it
developed black's pieces the bishop on
g7 is now a fine piece yeah and here
again we get to to a critical point here
white only has the choice between two
evils basically you can allow the night
to jump to f5 getting black a very nice
strategically comfortable position where
I have the pressure on deform no bad
pieces and I would have loved to play
this with the with the with the night
coming to f5 um yeah this didn't happen
he now played f5 which was the strange
thing he could have done that before
hand and only now we did it maybe if we
go back maybe he saw after g4 f5 maybe
he saw some idea that his his queen
would be trapped but this is simply not
the case I mean there is no way here to
to trap the Queen there's still age 7
hanging and you also have aged for ya
which is a bit weird looking maybe but
you're not going to get your queen
trapped maybe he miscalculated something
there yeah well as mentioned he now
played at five but now the problem is
this is a somewhat isolated warrior here
on f5 it's completely unsupported Bishop
c8 attacking this and now he played the
book to f2 yeah if I take now on d5 on
f5 there's g5 thing so I first protected
this and and now I expected him to to to
protect it with luke to f1 yeah like
this sorry this is what he played to
protect it with Luke everyone after that
I play rubgy to f8 and increase the
pressure on their five black is much
more comfortable here I can easily
protect the Pawnee on g4 if necessary
and f5 is just the target so black is
much much better already however he
played 92 which was a bit of a surprise
because well I can just take it he
probably am had miscalculated something
as now he took on f5 he it seems that he
relied on this idea takes and look
everyone sort of yeah attacking both
bishops here but it's simply not working
because I have air actually if more than
one replied to that I can play Bishop g5
securing um the piece or i can play rook
to e8 which I did and yeah now black is
a pawn up and an exchange up and yeah
there's really nothing that white can do
he gave the check if we look at rook
air-five briefly I just take here and
the bad thing is that black's pieces are
co-ordinated
nicely so white will lose even more
material here if we look at this the the
night is hanging so probably something
like this and this is going to happen
yeah and then if you move the night d 4
is falling and okay you can instead of
protecting you can take here but rookie
to its going to win all the pawns and to
our test no no counter play whatsoever
um yeah he went Bishop f4 check King b7
and Bishop b5 yeah okay I can just take
him and recaptured and Ruby five so an
exchange and two pawns yeah the rest is
pretty simple technical play 94 Bishop
g6 yeah I went to do six because this is
a nice spot for the bishop it is always
protected by the pawn and it covers f7
so white cannot activate this rook and
play droog f6 yeah here I had a choice I
can also play c5 here but I covered with
rook c8 it's not a it's not a big
difference yeah this i had seen 96 but
ok you you're an exchange of and two
pawns so it's no need to to be overly
materialistic i just played rook e1 here
and rugby one attacking a further porn
hear the beep on and offering to return
the exchange he didn't take it if I if
he takes I just take yeah and this is
three points with a completely
coordinated position everything's
covered no threats Jay he went with this
check check and yet another check
getting in some some spy checks so to
say well I can just play b5 and there is
still this hanging with check yeah white
can take on c6 also with the rook here
but check it was just wins the house he
played night takes and after that um
yeah I can also take me too but I
decided to play with f7 getting the
roofs off which simplifies matters it
allowed him to to to play a double check
always funny
but it's really not much more than this
is what it is a check night XD five chat
exchanged here check took here yeah and
hereafter ok to use some able to take b5
the easiest is to play a 6 keeping this
pawn and attacking a 2 and that will
just take it next move we can do that
but after check this and this I'm going
to win the pot anyway winning with the
two protected too connected passes here
on the queenside yeah so a pretty
convincing win at least I thought um and
I think when that shows you need to
prepare for your opponent not in only in
terms of concrete lines but to choose
what position type you want I saw that
you really always played this very
schematic chess so I thought getting
some sort of a symmetrical and an
unconventional position would be a good
thing and it I think it showed pretty
quickly that he couldn't really handle
this too well when you went with Queen
age 5 which was ok but here I am this
this that you didn't play at five but
Queenie 5 and the end the trade here
this was I guess one effect of the
somewhat unusual position that he was
not not used to you also spent lots of
time really lots of time which probably
wouldn't have happened if we got them
one of those some standard positions
that he has on the border all the time
yeah this was of course in terms of the
tournament as standings a very important
win as it brought me back to a score
brought me to a good score or four out
of five which meant that the next round
I got very strong Grandmaster opponent
again so look forward to the video on
round six when I play a grandmaster
again thanks for watching